[Music]
Olivia Jade and Isabella Gianelli were
burning up the dance floor at the Jonas
Brothers concert on Monday Lorie
Laughlin's daughters were spotted at the
band's concert at the Hollywood Bowl
where they shared a box with two friends
and spent the night dancing singing and
taking pics on a disposable camera we
were freaking out and ETI witness says
the sisters appeared to really enjoy
themselves and even stayed for the
entire show Olivia's boyfriend
Jackson Guthrie sat in a box nearby
enjoying beers with three pals but that
didn't stop the lovebirds from running
to each other seats throughout the night
to hang out at one point the two met
Midway where they smooched it up in the
aisle as the Joe Broz performed Nick's
solo hit jealous
[Music]
[Applause]
Olivia and Jackson were also seen slow
dancing and sharing a few kisses during
the group's 2007 ballad when you look me
in the eyes
[Music]
Isabella shared this clip from the
performance to her insta story writing
my 10 year old self is so happy right
now
I just want them to have that experience
and get that education and have a degree
to fall back on the outing comes after
ET learned that Olivia and Isabella are
no longer enrolled at USC back in March
news broke that Lori and her husband
Massimo were accused of paying the
university five hundred thousand dollars
in bribes in order to get the girls
admitted as crew recruits even though
neither of them ever participated in the
sport they do want them to have somewhat
of a normal you know finish out of high
school college experience maybe because
I didn't have that I would really want
that for them in April the couple
submitted not guilty pleas but are still
awaiting their fate we're just a nice
normal family you know like we don't we
don't have anything outrageous really
had a source a recently told et that
Lori's anxiety is through the roof about
the impending case but her relationship
with her daughters has drastically
improved since the scandal initially
broke a source previously told ET quote
what started as Olivia cutting herself
off from her mother has been a complete
turnaround both girls have joined
together because they both feel their
mother only wanted the best for them her
daughters are now much closer than they
have ever been
you